في حدث اليوم نتوقف عند دخول الحاضر
الاوروبي على النفط الروسي حيز التنفيذ
سعيد بان يكون معي من برلين رائد نعيم ما
هو محلل سياسي واقتصادي رائد هل يمكن
بالفعل ان نسمي هذا الحظر حظرا
كما قيل اوروبيا خاصه او حصلت بعض
الاستثناءات لبعض الدول
هو اهلا وسهلا
القرار الجديد ليس حاضر واكمال لاجراءات
الحظر التي بدات منذ مده والحضر كما قلت
ان كان فيه اصلا استثناءات كثيره ولم يؤثر
على الاقتصاد الروسي كما كان مامولا له
سبب اعاده توجيه ال- همم
[موسيقى]
نفط الروسي الى اسواق اخرى مثل فلسطين
والهند الاجراء الجديد هو تفسير لسعر همم
في السوق العالميه وهو اجراء دائما صعب
يعني صعب جدا فلا اتوقع له نجاح كبيره
بصراحه
الغريب في الامر وانت سمعت بالتاكيد ان
دول تتاجر بهذا الحذر ان دول ان تشتري
نفطا روسيا بسعر رخيص
وتعيد بيعه الى اوروبا باسعار غريبه يعني
يعني دخلنا فيه دخلنا في لعبه قط- قط
والفار تدفع ثمن
طبعا سياساتك هذه تخلق بطبيعتها سوق سوداء
للمحضور عليها او
للنف في هذه الحاله
اعتقد ان الموضوع اكبر من ذلك اعتقد ان
روسيا لديها بدائل ليست سيئه في مقابله
همم تسقيف السعر الذي تقوم فيه اا يكون في
الاتحاد الاوروبي مع الدول السابقه لانه
هناك همم اسواق اخرى قد يتم اعاده توجيه
النفط الروسي اليها هناك التلاعبات
الممكنه هناك همم فرصه حتى لروسيا بان
تخلق بدائل للنقل وللتامين والدعم المادي
وهي ال- همم الثلاث الامور التي سيطارها
حاضر همم يمكن ان تخلق بدائل خاصه بها اذا
تمت همم تم ذلك الاتفاق مع همم موردين
كبار بالتفصيل والجلد همم
طيب عندما ترى كميات النفط التي اشتريت من
قبل العديد من الدول الاوروبيه قبل ان
يدخل الحذر حيث تنفيذ يعني تتسائل بالفعل
ماذا يريد الاوروبيون في النهايه
الحظر ولكن قبل الحظر نشتري يعني
اعتقد هذه السياسات طويله المدى طبعا لا
يمكن اتحاد اوروبي للتخلي عن كميات
ورجاء من روسيا بين يوميا اعتقد ان
الاتحاد الاوروبي يفرض سياسته واا
واحده تلو الاخرى ليكون هناك مجال ايضا
بخلق مدائن الاتحاد الاوروبي
واعتقد ان قرارات مثل هذه ممكن ان تكون
مجرد ورق ورقه يريد التحدث اوروبي او تريد
الولايات المتحده في المفاوضات او في
المفاوضات قادمه حول وقف الاطلاق النار في
اوكرانيا او حول حتى توصل للاتفاق سلام من
نوع اعتقد الاساس الضاغط وراء هذا القرار
بالذات همم تدخل في اسواق في سعر همم في
السوق العالميه والمطر العالميه هي
الولايات المتحده بالاساس وليس اوروبا همم
قامت بالحاضر بشكل شامل وهمم اكمل
الاجراءاتها اعتقد انها تدخل همم بشكل
صريح ومباشر في اسعار النفط الروسي في
السوق العالمي همم هو يعني اراده امريكيه
اكثر من من فيها اوروبيه وقد تكون للرد
ايضا على سياسات اوبل كلاس التي لم تكن
للولايات المتحده راضيه عنها في الفتره
طيب عندما نتحدث عن هذه الموجه من
العقوبات حتى عندما اتخذ هذا القرار هناك
قرار اخر واستكمال هذه العقوبات في شهر
فبراير بعقوبات اضافيه يعني العقوبات
لذاته سوف تكون يعني سد الذغراء ثغرات
الموجوده في هذه العقوبات الحاليه لا كما
قلنا العقوبات دائما تراكميه لانها يجب ان
تتيح للمعاقب فرصه ان ان همم يخلق بدائل
العقوبات التي تصدق في شهر فبراير هي
عقوبات الاساس للمشتقات النفطيه همم
القادمه من روسيا وهذا امر قد يكون له
تاثير اكبر على امر مثل تصفيه السعر همم
سعر النفط الخام همم في السوق العالميه
اعتقد الحظر الكامل على مشتقات النفط
الروسي مباشره في الاتحاد الاوروبي سيؤثر
من حجم التبادل ما بين همم روسيا والاتحاد
الاوروبي وهذه المشتقات اعاده توجيهها الى
اسواق اخرى اصعب من اعاده توجيه النقل
قد يكون هناك تاثير مثل هذه ال ال
قناه مستقله اكبر من تصنيف النفط في السوق
الدولي طيب حتى التسقيف فكره التسقيف
تثيره جدلا حتى داخل اوروبا هناك دول تعرف
طبيعه
بغض النظر عن ان بعض الدول الاوروبيه او
مصالح الدول الاوروبيه قد تختلف في
تعاملها مع
الحاضر بشكل عام
واعتمادها على همم الطاقه القادمه
هناك خرق في هذا الموضوع لاساسيات التعامل
الدولي في السوق الحره همم السوق الحره
تعتمد على على العرض والطلب ولا يمكنك ان
تبدا بالتحكم بها عن طريق تصفيف السعر اذا
بدات الولايات المتحده او لا بداء الاتحاد
الاوروبي اليوم
بالتلاعب باسعار همم مواد معينه في السوق
العالميه بتخفيف من تصفيف النفط الروسي من
سمنع الدول الاخرى مثل الصين او روسيا حتى
الى القيام في امور مشابهه همم كل همم
الامور التي كانت تحدد السعر في السوقيه
التحكم في العرض او التحكم في الطلب طبعا
التحكم في طلب صعب جدا في موضوع الخامس
التحكم في العرض هو كان سبيل الوحيد ولذلك
سيدنا سياسات اوفيسو مدى الترقب الولايات
المتحده لقرارات القادمه ايضا هناك همم
بالمناسبه يعني امكانيه لروسيا ان ان ان
تستغل تاثيرها في داخل الدول
من من همم باتجاه تخفيض الانتاج
لرفع سعر همم
بشكل عام
والاستفاده من ذلك في التبادل التجاري
بينها وبين الدول التي لن تلتزم بقرار همم
طيب عندما اتخذ هذا القرار سمعنا الهدف
الهدف هو منع روسيا من الامكانيات لتمويل
الحرب في اوكرانيا روسيا الان تقول لنا
سنتوقف عن تصدير اوكي
ستوقف هذا التصدير يعني من يصدق ان روسيا
لن تجد
يعني دول اخرى ستشتري منها النفط
روسيا دول
حتى لو التزمت بدون ان تعلن الالتزام
اليوم بهذا
التستهي لن تخسر شيئا لان تصنيف في 60
دولار من البرميل
السعر الذي تمنحه روسيا لدول مثل الصين
والهند اليوم
مع العلم بان تكلفه انتاج البرميل هي بين
20 و25 دولار للبرميل
لن يكون هناك خسائر على ارادات روسيا
روسيا لديها همم امكانيات كثيره للتعامل
ومنها ان همم توافق بصم على الموضوع حتى
تتغير الاسعار يعني اليوم هي لن تخسر
الالتزامها بالصف السادس
طيب للتحدث الان تاثير هذه العقوبات على
الاقتصاد الروسي هل بالفعل هي عقوبه من
شانها ان تنهيك الاقتصاد الروسي
مباشر قصير المدى على
الاقتصاد الروسي كونه جزءا من حزمه
قرارات
لحصار روسيا فاا علينا ان نرى الحزمه
باكملها اعتقد الحزمه باكملها نعم اذا كان
هناك حضر لمشتقات اذا كان هناك تقليل من
من استيراد الغاز الى اخره الى اخره اعتقد
هذه لها تبيعات لان اعاده توجيه عن
التصدير الروسي محدوده الاقتصاد الروسي
يمكنه اعاده توجيه النفط الخام ولكنه لا
يمكنه اعاده توجيه المواد اخرى مثل
المشتقات البترول او من همم او همم خامات
اخرى ليس همم السوق العالميه بحاجه ماسه
اليها همم مثل النقطه الثانيه ولكن هناك
همم دول ربما مثلا تنتهي هذه الفرصه واذكر
على سبيل المثال تركيا مثل ماذا حظناه في
قضيه الحبوب
صحيح يمكن يمكن ان ان ان يكون ذلك اعتقد
ان الاهم من تركيا هي موقف الصين
من المتوقع ان يعود الاقتصاد الصيني الى
التنامي بعد ان قلل تلاميذ بسبب السياسات
كوبيد في في الصين يعني للعلم مجرد سياسات
كوبيد في الاونه الاخيره قللت من طلب صيني
على البترول فيما يعادل 900 الف برميل
يوميا حجم التبادل التجاري بين روسيا
واتحاد اوروبي في في في الوقت الطبيعي كان
مليون ونصف ترميه فهنا هناك امكانيه كبيره
اذا عادت مثلا قوه
الصيني همم بان يكون هناك امكانيه همم
لروسيا بعد التوجيه ال- ال- الالكتروني
يعني هناك طبعا امكانيه ولكنها تبقى في ما
في ما يتعلق بغير ال ال البترول الخام
محدوده بعض الشيء وتستلزم تعاون اكبر هل
يؤثر هذا على سعر النفط له
اعتقد على المستوى القصير
في سعر النفط ولكن
ان ان نرى تغير بشكل كبير سواء انخفاض او
ارتفاع في في ذلك حتى بدايه العام القادم
يعني انا اعتقد في فبراير مارس اذا همم
استكملت العقوبات واذا همم راينا ماذا
يحدث في الاقتصاد الصيني همم فهناك همم
يمكن اعتبارا ههه اوروبا ستدفع الثمن ام
لا
حتى الان ليس ليس تمانا لتثبيت السعر ولكن
طبعا كل حرب تجاريه هي لها ثمن وليس هناك
رابح في اي حرب تجاريه وحرب صديقتك
الجانبان سيخسران ولكن يعني الريف
والخساره هي قائمه طويله يجب ان نضع خطا
في النهايه
اعتقد ان الحرب والازمه همم كفتها لا زالت
في صالح الاتحاد الاوروبي والولايات
المتحده همم اعتقد ان تداعيات ازمه الطاقه
لم تكن بالشده او بال- اا بالتاثير الكبير
للتوقعه للوقوتن همم على الاقتصاد
الاوروبي او على طلب على العلاقه حتى الان
همم الاقتصاد الاقتصاد الاوروبي لم يخسر
الكثير من جراحه
برلين شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا جزيلا
ابقوا معنا على فرنس فتكات
[موسيقى]